en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología y debido a la
emergencia que vivimos a causa de la
pandemia de ccoo y 19 nos adaptamos
desde nuestros hogares para llevarles
toda la información -soy valentina
torres sánchez gracias por acompañarme
en esta ocasión iniciamos hablando de
las enseñanzas que ha dejado del cobi 19
cuando el mundo superó el millón de
muertes a pesar de que los contagios
siguen en aumento los fallecimientos no
registran las tendencias alarmantes de
hace unos meses aún faltan datos clave
del virus pero este tiempo ha permitido
importantes avances en principio está el
uso de fármacos que ya existían para
tratar a pacientes con síntomas graves
es el caso de la dexametasona ahora
sabemos que para pacientes con
respiradores se puede reducir la
mortalidad en un tercio con un
tratamiento simple económico y
disponible ampliamente no sabíamos eso y
ahora lo sabemos
reduce el tiempo de hospitalización
aunque no sabemos si mejorar las
oportunidades de sobrevivir pero
mantener a la gente fuera del hospital o
reducir su estadía es importante
asimismo estos meses han permitido
descartar otros medicamentos que en
algún momento parecieron prometedores no
sabemos que la hidroxi cloroquina no
funciona para pacientes en el hospital
de hecho sabemos que los pino billiton
hay un tratamiento ampliamente
recomendado para el vih a funciones web
en la actualidad se sigue investigando
si el plasma de convalecencia o plasma
de pacientes que han superado la
enfermedad puede funcionar para aumentar
las defensas de personas sanas asimismo
se estudia si los anticuerpos producidos
en animales como los caballos o las
alpacas tienen la capacidad de
neutralizar el virus otro punto que aún
no se ha esclarecido es cuánto dura la
inmunidad que puede lograr un recuperado
pues ya se han documentado varios re
contagios en el mundo sin embargo la
investigación más importante que se
lleva a cabo
es la producción de una vacuna eficaz y
segura actualmente numerosos países
están en la carrera por conseguir el
fármaco entre los más sonados están
estados unidos reino unido rusia y china
la organización mundial de la salud ha
sido enfática en que no estará
disponible a gran escala en principio
pero luego cuando haya suficientes dosis
se necesita una repartición equitativa
when we have band y efectiva sing cuando
tengamos una vacuna efectiva tenemos que
usarla efectivamente in time export
action in crisis we want all pero en el
tiempo cuando la producción se
incremente queremos que todos tengan
acceso a las vacunas pero inicialmente
cuando los recursos sean limitados la
prioridad debe ser vacunar a los
trabajadores esenciales ya quienes están
en mayor riesgo incluyendo los mayores y
personas vulnerables incluyen over
pitbull en dosis underline condicións
justamente con este fin la o ms la
alianza de vacunas gabi y otras
instituciones crearon el kóvacs un
mecanismo que apoya en la investiga
y desarrollo y fabricación de las
candidatas a vacuna 9 de estos fármacos
ya están dentro de la iniciativa y
aunque curiosamente hay candidatos
estadounidenses y dos chinas estas
naciones se negaron a ser parte de la
plataforma que ya está integrada por más
de 170 países ahora nuestro objetivo es
tener dos mil dosis de la vacuna
disponibles para el final de 2021 y
twenty one la intención es que todas
esas naciones tengan acceso equitativo
al fármaco por lo que una vez que esté
disponible de manera amplia los países
tendrán destinada una tasa proporcional
a su población junto con el impulso
obligado de las investigaciones la
pandemia ha generado una aceleración en
el desarrollo de varias tecnologías
entre ellas las comunicaciones virtuales
tanto en consultas médicas como en el
contacto familiar se han vuelto clave en
este tiempo también se han creado
numerosos dispositivos como chalecos o
collares que alertan a las personas si
están manteniendo o no correctamente la
distancia social en empresas o espacios
cerrados
asimismo los robots cada vez son más
usados en ámbitos como el reparto de
mercancías como meseros y cocineros y en
el aseo y últimamente los avances son
tan grandes que ya pueden tomar pruebas
de covite este robot se llama syrah v2 y
fue desarrollado en egipto el robot
puede tomar pruebas con hisopos puede
tomar pruebas de sangre y monitorear
signos vitales como la temperatura
cardíaco y otras medidas que el médico
puede necesitar de internet y usa el
internet de las cosas por lo que se
entrena a sí mismo y el rol del
desarrollador es mínimo en taiwán esta
vez en 96 un brazo robótico que puede
tomar analizar y entregar los resultados
de unas 2000 pruebas a diario
diseñamos las acciones de este brazo
robótico imitando las acciones humanas
para evitar más contagios
tenemos la certificación que asegura que
no quedan residuos en su interior para
asegurar que las pruebas funcionan
perfectamente
perfecto los más de 30 millones de
contagios y los rebrotes en lugares
donde parecía que el virus ya estaba
controlado han dejado claro que por el
momento es clave continuar con las
medidas de distanciamiento social pues
aunque los jóvenes son quienes más están
contagiando actualmente al ser quienes
están asistiendo en lugares públicos al
volver a casa pueden contagiar a sus
familiares mayores que pueden requerir
hospitalización al desarrollar síntomas
graves por ello también es fundamental
continuar usando tapabocas y lavándose
las manos con frecuencia por favor
cuídense si es posible quédense en casa
recuerden que la salud es lo más
importante gracias por su compañía y
continúen con más en france 24 y
france24 puntocom
[Música]